I am in search of another planet in the
universe where life exists I can't see
this planet with my naked eyes or even
with the most powerful telescopes we
currently possess but I know that it's
there and understanding contradictions
that occur in nature will help us find
it on our planet where there's water
there's life so we look for planets that
orbit at just the right distance from
their stars at this distance shown in
blue on this diagram
four stars of different temperatures
planets could be warm enough for water
to flow on their surfaces as lakes and
oceans where life might reside some
astronomers focus their time and energy
on finding planets at these distances
from their stars what I do picks up
where their job ends I model the
possible climates of exoplanets and
here's why that's important there are
many factors besides distance from its
star that control whether a planet can
support life take the planet Venus it's
named after the Roman goddess of love
and beauty because of its benign
ethereal appearance in the sky but
spacecraft measurements revealed a
different story the surface temperature
is close to 900 degrees Fahrenheit 500
Celsius that's hot enough to melt lead
its thick atmosphere not its distance
from the Sun is the reason it causes a
greenhouse effect on steroids trapping
heat from the Sun and scorching the
planet's surface the reality totally
contradicted initial perceptions of this
planet from these lessons from our own
solar system we've learned that a
planet's atmosphere is crucial to its
climate and potential to host life we
don't know what the atmospheres of these
planets are like because the planets are
so small and dim compared to their stars
and so far away from us
for example one of the closest planets
that could support surface water
it's called Lisa 667cc
such a glamorous name right nice phone
number for a name it's 23 light years
away so that's more than 100 trillion
miles trying to measure the atmospheric
composition of an exoplanet passing in
front of its host star is hard it's like
trying to see a fruit fly passing in
front of a car's headlight okay now
imagine that car is 100 trillion miles
away and you want to know the precise
color of that fly so I use computer
models to calculate the kind of
atmosphere a planet would need to have a
suitable climate for water and life
here's an artist's concept of the planet
kepler-62f with the earth for reference
it's 1,200 light-years away and just 40%
larger than Earth our nsf-funded work
found that it could be warm enough for
open water for many types of atmospheres
and orientations of its orbit so I'd
like future telescopes to follow up on
this planet to look for signs of life
ice on a planet surface is also
important for climate ice absorbs longer
redder wavelengths of light and reflects
shorter bluer light that's why the
iceberg in this photo looks so blue the
redder light from the Sun is absorbed on
its way through the ice only the blue
light makes it all the way to the bottom
then it gets reflected back up to our
eyes and we see blue ice my models show
that planets orbiting cooler stars could
actually be warmer than planets orbiting
hotter stars there's another
contradiction that ice absorbs the
longer wavelength light from cooler
stars and that light that energy heats
the ice using climate models to explore
how these contradictions can affect
planetary climate is vital to the search
for life elsewhere and it's no surprise
that this is my specialty I'm an
african-american female astronomer and a
classically trained actor who loves to
wear makeup and read fashion
so I am uniquely positioned to
appreciate contradictions in nature and
how they can inform our search for the
next planet where life exists my
organization rising star girls teaches
astronomy to middle school girls of
color using theater writing and visual
art that's another contradiction science
and art don't often go together but
interweaving them can help these girls
bring their whole selves to what they
learn and maybe one day join the ranks
of astronomers who are full of
contradictions and use their backgrounds
to discover once and for all that we are
truly not alone in the universe thank
you